hello everybody so as most of you know
although I do like talking about
symbolism most of my time I spend here
in my workshop carving icons and for the
last two years I've had a project where
I've been exploring the different forms
of icon carving through drawing now it's
been two years just this month in
November I sent out all of the stuff
that people who have been supporting me
or getting I'm sending out postcards I'm
sending out posters and also for people
who are giving at the twenty five dollar
level I'm sending an actual drawing that
I made and I was thinking to myself
where do we go now how could I make it
even more valuable and so what I decided
to do is rather to push it even further
this past year as many of you know
because of everything because of the
YouTube because of because the
conference's it has been a major year of
transition but through the fact that
people have been supporting me through
patreon and people have been buying my
carvings and inviting me to give talks I
am ready to make a major transition in
my workshop and I'm just a few weeks ago
I hired an assistant who is going to be
working with me in the workshop and one
of the things we want to do is of course
speed up my icon carving he'll be taking
out the backgrounds you know cleaning up
things doing the finishing through the
polishing doing all the kind of
preparatory work that I usually have to
do myself and what that's going to do is
it's going to speed up my production but
what it's also doing is freeing up some
time and some energy for me to explore
icon carving now at the next level and
so this year for my development project
I'm not only going to be doing drawings
I will still be doing some drawings
maybe not as many but we will be with my
assistant together we'll be exploring
whole new venues of carving I want to
look at how to join mosaics into my
carving I've done a little bit of that
but we're going to take that to the next
level
I've also acquired a kiln and the
soapstone that I'm using can be fired in
the kiln
be playing around with that firing the
soapstone adding some glazes and so
there's a whole lot of things that we're
going to explore in the carving itself
not only that but in terms of subject as
well what I intend to do is to stretch
out the subjects that I've been
exploring until now I've been doing
mostly ikon carving but now from now on
what I want to do is also look at other
types of imagery I want to explore the
whole history of early Western Byzantine
art doing some maybe fantastical beef
some ornamentation all kinds of new
images that hopefully will be appealing
to a wider audience and that might
include the people who are watching this
now so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to open up this patreon project drawing
project for just development of my craft
and if you support me on patreon you'll
still be getting stuff I'll still be
sending postcards and posters and
drawings too for people giving it 25 but
this year you might be getting a whole
lot more in terms of choice I'll be
sending out all these new projects are
doing more colorful with with colored
stone and by we might be trying to use
paint as well trying to color the
carvings trying all kinds of stuff and
hopefully so it will create a more
exciting thing that you can follow on
patreon and on social media and the
extra thing I'm going to do is all these
new things we're going to develop we're
going to offer them for all the patrons
first pick
so exclusively for patrons I'm going to
put up these carvings on patreon so if
people want to buy these these new these
new things that are coming out and then
if I see that they're not going on
patreon then I'll post them on the
website and on social media but in the
last year what I've seen is every time I
put something up for sale I usually sell
it within an hour so if you're excited
about that I would suggest that you come
join me on patreon people can start to
give even only a $2.00 a month and now
you'll get some postcards but then there
are different tiers that you can follow
depending on on what would you like to
get for me and just how excited you are
about this project join my patreon and
as usual everybody thank you for your
support and now yeah looking forward to
see what the new year is going to bring